I just have to tell you that I just met
some of the most amazing people we met
patients that were absolutely terribly
wounded and the doctors the nurses all
of the people of the hospital have done
a job that's indescribable what I saw
today is just an incredible tribute to
professionalism and what they have done
is incredible and you never want to see
it again that I can tell you that was
the president earlier today praising the
actions of all the doctors who work to
save the lives of the hundreds of
shooting victims on Sunday joining us
now is Clark County Fire Department
Chief Greg castle he was at the scene of
the shooting also with us dr. Scott
Scheer and dr. Kevin Menace both how
patients wounded by this gunman guys
you're amazing heroes how many patients
did you guys see as this was unfolding
so we saw 200 patients at Sunrise
Hospital most of them came in probably
within the first hour hour and a half
and and how many may have died without
the care you're offering I can't even
quantify that I mean the job that our
staff did physicians nurses volunteers
ancillary staff is just absolutely
amazing the response that we got we we
had a hundred physicians show up that
night after they were called we had a
hundred nurses and you practice for this
I saw like twice here
yeah about twice here yeah amazing
doctor I know by the way all all the law
enforcement guys here love you because
you work with law enforcement and you've
helped them a lot tell us about that
that dreadful time for you you know I
don't take the dreadful part you know I
think everything that we did that night
as a team but I don't regret anything
that we did I think we saved every life
that could have possibly be
you know there were over 200 people that
were dropped off at our er in less than
an hour and I guess it's sort of like a
war zone you have to prioritize the
severity of the injuries and you went
through that process it's part of mass
casualty is the triage process is making
sure that the patient that is is deemed
red or the sickest patient gets to the
areas either into the operating suite or
in front of the ER doc or a trauma
surgeon right away and you look at these
people and I just have a lot of friends
that are doctors and I know you think I
got to get this dad home I got to get
this kid home to their parents
does that go through your mind or you
you can't go there you know in the
moment while I was doing it I had
seconds I had 200 patients come into the
ER in you know a 60-minute time period
and I'm pulling patients out I was the
one I was the doctors pulling the
patients out of the car so I'm the one
who's making the initial judgment call
whether or not these patients were you
know red tags patients who were gonna
die within seconds or minutes you know
yellow tags as patients who are gonna
die in minutes or hours or green tags
they probably will be fine you know or
possibly they could get worse but you
know I had seconds to do this but you
know ahead of you what was amazing about
this whole thing was the patients were
the greatest patients I have ever taken
care of you know I got goobers taxis you
know Metro squad cars you know Clark
County fire city fire everybody was
taking public just to fire chief
everybody was state chief
honor to meet you all you guys you were
there as that's happening these guys you
try and get them to the hospital as fast
as possible yes all right this reminds
me in 911 I was in New York on 9/11 this
reminds me of all hands on deck I know
you must be so proud of your team I'm
very proud of our Fire Department all
the valley fire departments and our
private analyst partners a.m. our
community they they did a great job that
night they everybody amassed a ton of
resources available for patients to take
care of people in the street some people
did go by car but not not as many of
them after Whedon had laid hands on we
just they decided to go by car they they
didn't want to take an ambulance
whereas critically wounded but this was
an unreal surreal scene out here that
night it was nothing like I've ever seen
in 30 years of being involved in this
industry years and you're now the head
of the department and you've known these
guys I assume in the past or you know
the people at the hospital I know many
people at the hospital yes look you know
we sometimes throw around the word hero
sometimes all of you what you did for
people and there our need and the lives
you guys saved you know we're a grateful
nation because we have people with the
skill that you guys have and the courage
to to work under such heavy pressure
stress an under fire like that thank you
all for what you did really appreciate
it thank you all you're walking
sometimes